hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
hong kong chinese fantasy movie called
league of gods
during the reign of king joe an official
enters his bedchamber because he
disturbs king joe he is instantly
devoured by the monstrous tales of dagee
his concubine she is a demon fox who
disguises one of joe's concubines
outside their city several warriors of
the wing and depp tribe led by ji lay in
a metal wagon discuss their strategies
to free the invisible people tribe and
their chief cyril who have been
kidnapped by king joe after a while
jiangxia appears to them then he tells
them that when king joe was younger he
allowed himself to be possessed by the
black dragon because of his ambition to
rule the world the black dragon will
attack when the three suns converge
therefore darkness will cover the world
within the city king joe and danji held
a festival they decide to torture the
chief zero of the invisible people who
can predict the future using his eyes
the chief is forced to show king joe a
vision of himself pleading for mercy and
disintegrating away
unable to accept his future the king
immediately orders his guards to remove
the chief's eyes
at the same time the warriors are
sneaking into the prison where the
invisible people are located they
eventually fight several guards guarding
the prison after the fight g-la is
forced to use his powers to destroy the
metal bars that sealed the invisible
people tribe even though he was warned
earlier not to use them in the city
because of it his powers attract the
attention of a general name shang bao
aka general leopard he then rides on his
black leopard to pursue them
unfortunately several of the invisible
people are suddenly killed by more
guards
nonetheless the warriors manage to
escape with the invisible children who
use their powers to teleport to another
location
at the same time zhang zia arrives at
the festival and his powers cause the
time to stop but king joe is not
affected by his powers
meanwhile the group manages to arrive at
the sewer just as they are about to
continue their escape general leopard
appears behind them to stop him from
advancing any further g-la and his
friend jifa destroy a wall and create a
barrier using their powers
after they finish escorting the
invisible people to escape gilley and
jifa decide to go back inside and save
the chief
back to the festival it is revealed that
dodgy is also not affected by the
stopping time thus she quietly sends his
monstrous tales to zhang zia as he
avoids deji's tales unfortunately she
casts a magic spell at him which
reverses his age
knowing that he is in danger the chief
deliberately digs out his left eye and
throws it towards daijee to distract her
but then he gets destroyed by her tails
instead
not long after gilley and jifa also come
to help zhangzia but because dodgy's
power is too strong they cannot do much
finally they are able to escape with one
of the chief's eyes while the other eye
is obtained by dagi
afterwards they return to their capital
their king ji chang requests shang ziya
to use the chief's eye to find a way to
defeat king joe and the black dragon
from the chief's eye zhang ziya answers
that it is by using a sword known as the
sword of light which can only be used by
the chosen hero golden dragon besides
that they must find the sword before the
three suns converge in which the black
dragon will be released in the meantime
jang zia becomes younger as he warned
previously that taji cast a spell on him
that reverses his age
for each time he uses his magic the
reverse aging accelerates simultaneously
on the other side king joe and his
subordinates also know the same thing
because daijee has obtained one of the
chief's eyes
the next morning he is pensive on the
cliff because he is the only one who
does not have wings out of all the wing
adept tribe members with the support of
his friends below he immediately jumps
from the top of the cliff to grow his
wings unfortunately he still cannot grow
his wings either he then meets jang zia
who shows him a map where the sword of
light is located
jang zia tells him that he must take
three gifts from the spring of life with
him he also summons an egg from the well
from which a little boy called ninja
hatches and causes mischief meanwhile
general leopard constructs and animates
a wooden doll and he names her as landai
she is instructed to find and kill
gilley as her main mission
gilley and nejon depart into a wasteland
turns out that the first of jang zia's
gifts is a one-eyed plant who gives
g-lay some advices it can be seen that
nija enjoys playing with a plant while
suddenly the three are chased by a
legendary desert centipede-like worm
long story short g lay is able to kill
the monster
after that neja secretly steals from
g-la the second gift which is a baby
dragon prince whose growth was stunned
by him
surprisingly it subdues the quickly
grown knee job by breathing a gas on him
making him unconscious while turning him
into an adult
upon waking g-lay forces him to help him
find the sword of light at first he
refuses to help gillet finding the sword
but then he finally agrees after g-la
promises to help him to find his
legendary weapon the fire wheels
they continue on their journey until
they arrive into a collection of pillars
within a marsh which turn into a palace
in a desert not far from them there is a
hermit manipulates sand with his magic
chicken
annoyed that knee jaw suddenly bothers
him the hermit immediately attacks them
but later he is defeated the hermit is
revealed to be erlang shen
afterwards jilay gives him the third of
zhang ziya's gifts which is his faithful
dog howling celestial he then leaves
them behind to continue the search for
his golden father
at night they travel to a port where
they encounter landai who is
entertaining the children around with
glowing butterflies
jilay is attracted to her beauty but she
decides to leave him after getting
acquainted for a while because she
immediately sends all the information
she got to general leopard meanwhile
chile finds a sorceress named taizenren
unluckily she immediately uses ji lei's
dreams to read into his mind after being
woken by the plant gilay tries to steal
the artifact that they use as a ship to
sail out of the port suddenly landai
goes inside with her memories already
lost because she just transferred all
her memories to general leopard
therefore she is asking about the
artifact causing tyee to wake up and
directly attack them with her power just
as they are about to steal the artifact
they manage to run away using the
artifact which turns into a ship
it is supposed to sail to any location
that its user desires
while on the ship nija torments the baby
dragon prince consequently
it breathes gas on him again to put him
to sleep and reverting him back to a
child
at that moment landai explains to julie
that she knows about the sword of light
because she could read his mind
shortly after general leopard suddenly
takes her memory again causing her to
faint because of his sympathy geelay
breaks the flow of memories that are
coming out from her head making general
leopard even angrier
the next day julie wonders why the ship
is going to the middle of the ocean the
plant immediately answers that it is
because the baby dragon prince has
controlled the ship to his father's
territory as the dragon prince sings the
dragon king of the east sea hears him
and orders his giant monster straight
away to bring neja and his son back to
him
on the other hand g-lay cannot help need
jaw because it is his own problem
while in the sea palace nija demands the
dragon king to return his fire wheels to
him the dragon king orders his guards to
attack him but he defeats the guards by
urinating and passing gas at them at the
end the dragon king surrenders by giving
him the fire wheels
he also gives the dragon prince in
exchange
with his legendary weapon nija turns
into an adult and flies away back to the
ship
the ship is now able to fly to gilley's
former home which is now in ruins it is
revealed that his father was killed by
an invading army of king joe who
exterminated most of the wing adepts and
his father's wings were torn off his
back
later he is able to find the sword of
light which is guarded by several
rapidly moving rings that surround its
floating island after that general
leopard suddenly arrives with a fleet of
flying ships to steal the sword he
eventually manages to subdue g-lay in
exchange for g-la's life landai
overcomes the rapid rings and retrieves
the sword as soon as possible but it
inadvertently destroys the rings and
blows general leopard in his fleet away
in that precarious situation he is
finally able to grow his new wings and
carries the dying land die to see the
sunset she turns into a wooden mannequin
and he leaves her to rest at the island
while taking the sword with him
as he notices the sun beginning to
converge he goes back to the capital
with nija and erlang shen who has found
his golden father on the other hand the
capital is now under siege by king joe's
army as jiangxia struggles to use the
city's defense system properly because
he starts to forget about it which is
the effect of the reverse aging
meanwhile taji uses her magic power to
revive general leopard which turns him
into a horrible monster
the three heroes return with a sword of
light to find jang zia being reverted to
a young boy after a moment they fight
the horrible general leopard who during
the fight kills ji chang in the end
because of this zhang ziya is left
unprotected and he meets taji's tale
with ji chang's dying condition he
passes his command and the sword to jifa
he then rushes to the spring of life and
dives in to charge the sword as the
others distract the monster
soon chiffon merges as the golden dragon
with his new charged sword and kills
general leopard immediately the movie
ends with jifa mobilizing his forces for
a counter-attack and flying his fortress
towards the king joe's kingdom at that
time king joe has turned into the black
dragon waiting for the heroes to attack
it can be seen that there is baby janxia
in their possession
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching